Modern Warfare Season 3 brings new
content to Modern Warfare itself as well
as the standalone warzone let's break
down all the important info you need to
know season 3 kicks off on April 8th and
the first batch of goodies drops during
launch week to start there are three new
6v6 multiplayer maps tall seek backlot a
remaster of a map from the original game
is a desert city with construction going
on in the center it should be a good map
for both close quarters and long range
firefights Kovach sawmill is a brand-new
three lane map set in a village with a
sawmill currently on fire you can battle
in the fiery rubble in other shops in
town or above on various rooftops
finally there's a Naya incursion a twist
on the existing anaya palace map this is
an enclosed portion of that map intended
for smaller team sizes multiplayer
playlists featuring these maps will be
continually released as the season moves
forward warzone isn't left out either
you'll be able to play quads in both
battle royale and plunder warzone we'll
also get more modes and playlists as the
season continues additionally activision
promised more weapons speaking of which
the SKS sniper rifle and Renetta pistol
are joining both warzone and modern
warfare in season 3 so that answers what
and where you'll be playing but if
you're wondering who is joining the
roster the answer is Alex one of the
game's heroes is also the newest
operator he'll be playable in both
modern warfare and war zone you can get
Alex via the season 3 battle paths or
battle pass bundle the pass alone will
run you a thousand Co D points while the
bundle costs twenty four hundred the
battle pass has a hundred tiers of
rewards to unlock but the bundle will
instantly get you the first twenty which
includes a new category vehicle skins in
addition to Alex more operators will
join the fight in the coming weeks
Activision specifically named Ronin and
East scrub new maps are also coming
during the season
these include hardhat for standard
multiplayer and aisle eight for gun
fight the new maps will launch alongside
new modes including gun game reloaded
reinfected ground war activision also
teased a new classified weapon more
gunsmith customs and a scope sin shatter
guns mode for warzone in which you'll
only be able to wield snipers and sha DS
those are the highlights of modern
warfare season 3 and if you want to see
them in action GameSpot will have tons
of gameplay to check out too good luck
soldier